around the world monarchies are holding
up surprisingly well many are doing more
than just surviving they're thriving 44
countries have a monarch as head of
state since the Millennium only two
royal families have gone out of business
those of Samoa and Nepal where in 2001 a
murderous Nepalese Prince killed nine
family members and himself in effect
ending the Royal line in the 20th
century revolutions and two world wars
ended 110 monarchies so what's the trick
how do you keep a monarchy alive Queen
Elizabeth the second is perhaps the
best-known monarch she rules over 16
realms and 86 percent of Britons think
she's doing a good job this is partly
because she says nothing of consequence
in public
the British Royals have also proved they
can move with the times
welcoming a mixed-race American actress
into the fold in Thailand monarchs are a
political on paper but their close ties
with the Army have legitimized many
military coos undermining democracy
strict laws also protect the monarchies
image mild criticism of the royal family
and even their pets is landing
increasing numbers of people in prison
the power-hungry new king but Sheila
Longhorn is less popular than his father
and some wonder whether the institution
will survive under his rule in Saudi
Arabia the king and his Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman have absolute power
part of the Al Saud dynasty's success
comes from its wealth riches from oil
boost the country's economy creating
large pots of money to buy the loyalty
of subjects lavish welfare handouts are
used to keep the people happy and
well-paid goons are used to keep him
quiet on April 23rd the country executed
37 people many of them she is for
alleged terrorism
monarchs who survived today have
mastered the art of tightrope walking
the best maintained popular support by
staying out of politics putting their
country's interests before their own and
adapting with the times if they don't
they risk disappearing for good